hey today is a collapsing State we are
talking about the poorest nation in the
so-called West whose inhabitants are in
one of the most Bleak and depressing
situation of misery in the world hate is
the same of a tragedy that has been
going on for centuries which the
International Community doesn't seem
willing nor able to remedy the blame for
such a disaster lies not only with the
uncontrollable forces of nature but also
with the great Powers France and the
United States above all as well as the
rulers of Haiti themselves corrupt to
the core we are talking about a state
where it's common to eat Smart cakes
real mud cakes mixed with powder and
food grease a popular option in City
Soleil which is one of the poorest slums
in Porto France the capital where hunger
is a daily problem potopranz has now
fallen into the hands of gangs and has
turned into a kind of No Man's Land but
what are the origins of such chaos it is
possible to trace them it was just a
year ago this
was assassinated early this morning the
story of AIDS is perhaps one of the most
distressing and difficult to tell once
called The Jewel the ant hills the
island of Hispaniola now divided between
Haiti to the West in the Dominican
Republic to the east was the richest
colony in the entire world the ancient
Taino people composed of amiable
tractable peaceful engines as
Christopher Columbus has described them
in his letters were quickly decimated by
conquistadores by sword and disease the
sudden disappearance of the locals
however prompted the European settlers
to quickly look for another source of
Labor to exploit in the cultivation of
hispaniola's main resource sugar the
colonists opted to recruit as many
slaves as possible turning their sides
naturally to West Africa and finding a
solution in the infamous Atlantic route
in the span of 30 years from 1517 to
1540 more than 30 000 Africans were part
of the term imported to Hispaniola and
shortly thereafter the western part of
the island sales partially frequented by
Spanish gradually became a hold for
Buccaneers committing raids in the
Caribbean Sea many of them French
Frenchmen who in the mid 17th century
finally succeeded in establishing
themselves in the western quadrants of
the islands obviously in an entirely
illegitimate form naming it sandomang
Haiti alone came to account for as much
as 50 percent of the entire French gross
national products exporting to the old
continent not only sugar but also coffee
cocoa tobacco cotton Indigo and several
other products considered exotic It Is
by no means a coincidence that San
domain was at that time the richest
Colony on the globe and the most active
Mercantile Center in the new world the
entire Haitian Society was compressed by
rigid social castes in the 18th century
at the top were the Great Whites the
landowners the colonial Elites patched
up with Metropolitan French which
amounted to 40 000 individuals the
second social glass was the mulattos
born of unions in most cases violence
between whites and slaves and consisted
of just 28 000 people finally there were
the 450 000 slaves who led the life of
deprivation hunger and pain this slave
Colony observed the Marquis de River in
the late 18th century is like a city
ready to be attacked we are walking on
barrels loaded with gunpowder well
blowing up those barrels in 1789 came
the French Revolution inspired by the
ideals that had shocked Paris and tired
of the summary massacres carried out by
whites mestizos and the three slaves
under the leadership of the now free men
to San luvertu and The Fugitive jean-jac
desalin responded to violence with
violence I have given the French
cannibals Blood for Blood proclaimed
desoline considered the father of the
Asian nation and nicknamed the black
Napoleon I have Avenged America he said
the new Republic thus became the first
in independent nation of all Latin
America the second on the entire
continent anticipated only by the United
States in no other case throughout
history has an enslaved people being
able to break the chains of servitude
and defeats with a military response
finally the name sandomang was changed
to Haiti emerging out of the chaos
however was once again the ruling power
elite the three percent of the
population that had enjoyed greater
benefits and freedoms under the former
colonizers in which reintroduced the
typical slave system in other words the
French Colonial Legacy was perpetuated
by a simple Handover what's more
Haitians although three found themselves
living in a world completely hostile to
the idea of a territory self-governed by
blacks an independent Haiti was in fact
a nightmare for all those powers for
whom slavery was kinda normal starting
with the United States the so-called
International Community or rather at
that time Europe condemn attempt the hn
model which is that of a nation of freed
slaves it was for this reason that in
the Years following the independence
Europeans in the United States
coordinated to prepare a full-fledged
diplomatic embargo on the island France
refused to recognize Haiti existence as
a state and intimated that it was
necessary to pay compensation due to
land confiscation after the revolution
it's an absurdity since it's usually the
losers who have to pay compensation if
you think about it the request was
however formalized so to speak in 1825
when a French ship loaded with kennels
entered Porto Brands an emissary of King
Charles the tenth intimated to the
Haitians that they must pay a debt of
150 million francs to be paid in five
annual installments to repay the debts
Haiti sought and loan from a group of
French Max that's it in this way the
alliance economy sank and the state
coffers were depleted four generations
to come the impossibility of having an
economically sound nation was fertile
ground for cools and governments
assassinations indeed since 1855 the
average office of 18 presidents has
amounted to just one year there's no
question that being president of 80
shouldn't be a pleasant job we can be
reminded of this by the last Head of
State in chronological order juvenile
Moise who was killed in 2021 in his
presidential residence by unidentified
gang group as if that weren't enough the
U.S also got in the way as early as the
beginning of the 20th century the U.S
had practically taken possession of the
Dominican Republic days in half of
Espanola which in the previous course
had repeatedly gained independence from
Spain then in 1915 Woodrow Wilson gave
orders to initiate the invasion of 80 as
well in order to help the people the
interrupted French imperialism then
changed only in the origin of the master
Haiti was seen as an insult to
imperialism and the United states which
feared the German Investments began in
the late 19th century in the island
applied the so-called Monroe Doctrine
idealistically summarized as America to
Americans more pragmatically Wilson sold
a military base in the Caribbean Sea the
Marines took control of 80s tax revenues
and the National Bank forcing the
passage of a new Constitution that in
essence nullified the ban which was
established in 1804 that prevented any
Foreigner from owning land in the
country without a blow in short
Washington had created a new vessel
state that would remain loyal even after
the occupation ended in 1934 however the
occupation of the Dominican Republic had
already ended in 1924 but after six
years of Peace the United States
unleashed the coup that brought Rafael
Leonidas Trujillo to power license
bullet for the bloody end to the 31-year
dictatorship of Dominican strongman
Rafael Trujillo here with his brother
Hector on the Trujillo a nationalist
thinking was institutionalized and this
trades the origins of the Dominican
people back to the conquistadores they
mixed it with an anti-haitian sentiment
when in 1937 Trujillo had tens of
thousands of aliens residing in a
territory of the Dominican Republic
killed with a method that was peculiar
and simple and cruel in fact we referred
to this entire operation as the parsley
Massacre upon meeting the people the
military would ask them what it was all
about anyone who failed to correctly
pronounce the word perihil meaning
parsley in Spanish and telling the world
with a mousy R actually in English I
just found out that the typical or
French people say when speaking is
actually called French R not what did I
say a mouse yar
would automatically be considered a
francophone hence Haitian and thus
subject to physical elimination you
should know that since 1950 but
especially from 1946 onwards the United
States through various economic and
humanitarian Aid packages has wisely
played a key role in ATM politics great
the population is safe yes in an Earthly
reality like ours these subsidies simply
went into the wrong Pockets those of the
Haitian rulers the most rapacious to
take advantage of the so-called Western
benevolence was an intellectual at first
very well liked by many physician
Francois duvalier nicknamed papadoc de
villier was elected president in 1957.
however it took little time to turn him
into a dictator first papadoc organized
the personal vigilante Force these death
squads came to be nicknamed Tonton
makutz an appellation that according to
Haitian folklore was attributed to the
boogeyman who at night would kidnap
children by hiding them in a back it's
difficult to say how many people
disappeared at the hands of develier's
teams but the estimates are not the most
comforting their stock of tens of
thousands of desaparies basically if you
had any doubts about the volume this
could lead you to a Musgrave along with
your entire family nevertheless the
International Community didn't pay much
attention to Papa Doc's schizophrenic
Behavior indeed during his first four
and bloodiest years in power develier
received from Washington the beauty of
more than 40 million dollars most of it
in the form of outright gifts the White
House has reported in poor Farmers say
the uses of 80 had only one purpose to
keep dualie in power it was necessary to
prevent Haiti from going the way of
socialist scuba and continuing to serve
the interests of the US government
despite the fact that beginning in the
1960s thousands of Asians prefer to flee
on makeshift boats to the coast of
Florida in search of political Asylum
rather than remain training on the
islands corruption after all was so
entrenched as to be an accepted practice
throughout Haiti even today senior
government's officials exploit their
position to Ms power and wealth at the
expense of ordinary citizens and police
smuggle fuel which there is of course
shortage and then they sell it on the
black market on closer inspection even
the imposition of the official language
French testifies to the imbalances that
snake through a nation incapable of
coming to terms with the past in fact
Old State business is conducted in
French however only 10 percent of the
inhabitants are able to express
themselves in this language and less
than five percent speak it fluently
indeed the language of the masses is the
Haitian Creole the problem is that to be
successful in 80 you necessarily have to
speak French one result of this language
oppression is the Abominable National
illiteracy rate which approaches 90
percent in the cities and it's even
higher in rural areas the reason is that
people are needed Manpower in the fields
is needed for all those families who
cannot get by partly because the search
for work has driven almost all Haitians
to the capital the demographic imbalance
whereby the inhabitants of the entire
country total 11 million people in a
territory that is as vast as Tuscany for
example in Italy is a burden to another
long-standing problem on the island the
continuing destruction of the ecosystem
and the soil erosion try taking a look
at the satellite images nearby Haiti's
border with the Dominican Republic you
will notice how on the left the
vegetation appears to be much less
prominent what does this mean it means
that Haiti is a predominantly
mountainous country and over the past
200 years the people there have been
indiscriminately cutting down trees
without replanting them the spectacle
that unfolds every single year during
the five months of rainfalls where
rivers of mud slide down the mountain
slopes is just one of the visible
effects of the Savage deforestation
Nation the main reasons for Haitians to
destroy their land is the scarcity of
fuel with wood having been the only
material for lighting a fire for
centuries people can afford to cook
exclusively with charcoal which requires
large quantity of wood and here we are
to another hoax for the Haitian people
most of its best land domestically
produces crops for export not for the
domestic Market Haiti which would be an
agricultural country is nothing more
than a net importer of food if you are
wondering why stuff is it to say that
almost all of the land is controlled by
the three percent that represents the
Haitian Elites of course the money that
flows into the pockets of the local
oligarchy through export is not a
redistributed into the national economy
to build I don't know roads or hospitals
but it's spent in foreign markets the
United States Europe and the gulf
countries and so while a sugar cane
cutter can call himself lucky if he
earns one dollar a day the domestic and
foreign in companies let's be exploited
for the sake of Ferris U.S companies
that manage the land make Stellar
profits faced with a condition of
permanent exploitation one should
therefore not be surprised that so many
Haitians have joined organized crime and
gangs which are by the way the same of
papadox
continuing to serve the waves of aitian
History we come to 1990 the year when
pro-democracy Presbyterian John Bertrand
aristid incredibly won the presidential
election with 67 percent of the votes
this was an incredible result
considering the whole history of Haiti
but what happened well the Americans
came again forced aristid into Exile
imposed a dictator the U.N declared an
embargo on 80 and after four years Bill
Clinton came back to fix the disaster
that the United States themselves had
committed Harris State came back whose
deposed came back again was accused of
corruption and in 2000 0004 a good civil
war broke out or at least that was how
the U.N Justified the deployment of
minusta forces there is the United
Nations stabilization mission in Haiti
which was supposed to lead the country
through a democratic transition and if
you think you have already seen hell
know that until now we have solely
visited Purgatory Haiti has been the
same of natural disasters that destroyed
not only its Society but also any tiny
chance of getting back on its feet as
previously mentioned gangs in Haiti have
very clear intentions to take control of
the black market and manage the drug
trade but without assuming power even
should one gang be able to undermine the
others attempting a coupe would be very
counterproductive Haiti is already in
the hands of criminal gangs and
establishing a real government would
only mean losing the trust of those who
support them and see them as the only
solution to the current political
disaster this is well known by one of
portopran's most powerful leaders Jimmy
sharizi and Jose nickname by the way is
a barbecue I let you imagine why in
short here we are peering through the
gates of hell I confess to you that in
the face of so much anguish I have no
solution no moral to say at the end of
this video and yet I feel so much
frustrated with an International
Community that in concrete terms does
nothing at all except to make promises
and Promises in October 2022 for example
Henry requested a deployment of foreign
military forces in Port-au-Prince with
the aim of quelling the violent gang
Clash that had broken out the previous
July in successful Aid do you know who
answered the call yep the U.S a
tragicomic outcome for the situation of
a Nation Haiti that can neither rid
itself of its past nor free itself from
the evils that perennially Afflicted and
that unfortunately fall on the 11 and a
half million inhabitants who every
single day see their hopes fade more and
more in hates him the stars do not shine